naja so heller denn silke abfall und
ilona weber vor dem haus in dem sie in
berlin gemeinsam gelebt haben als sie
hier in jungen jahren wohnen ist ihr
leben alles andere als privatsache
vom treppenhaus gegenüber beobachten die
spitzel der stasi des ddr-geheimdienstes
sie durchs küchenfenster
früher hatte man von hier noch
ungehinderte sicht haben sie denn
gesehen wie die stasi leute hier
gestanden haben
das ist das land sie wissen es aus ihrer
stasi akte ein paar 100 blatt papier
abgefangene briefe private post amtliche
schreiben und vor allem berichte der
spitze am 30
84 um 7 uhr observationen am wohnort
aufgenommen in der küche brannte licht
und das fenster war halb geöffnet circa
50 minuten später wird das licht
gelöscht und die seeba verlässt allein
die wohnung und begibt sich zu fuß in
richtung u-bahn samariterstraße jemand
hat in meinen leben geguckt und ich
hatte keine ahnung davon und hat auch
mich als als person beschrieben aus
seiner sicht die nicht besonders
freundlich war es ist da aber es ist ja
nicht so und ich habe die erfahrung
gemacht dass man immer gut durchs leben
kommt er besser fährt wenn man
mit einer gegebenheit lebt
warum wurden die beiden als junge frauen
überwacht sie kamen aus der provinz
finden hier in der hauptstadt eine gut
bezahlte arbeit als schreibkräfte beim
neuen deutschland dem zentralorgan der
staatspartei sed
ausgerechnet aber sie wollen raus aus
der ddr 1976 stellen silka fall und
ilona weber immer neue ausreiseanträge
mit immer derselben begründung
ich zweifle an der glaubwürdigkeit
dieses staates da ich es am eigenen leib
zu spüren bekommen habe
wie wenig die menschenrechte in der ddr
geachtet werden
der nachwende generation müssen die
beiden erklären warum sie kopf und
kragen riskiert haben um die ddr zu
verlassen
ich will mir nicht vorschreiben lassen
wer bestimmt dass ich hier lebe das habe
ich noch nie einen gesehen also das war
schon vorher irgendwie dass ich mich
damit nicht einverstanden erklären
konnte und da hab ich gesagt nee also
ich will raus
ich will die freiheit beinahe wären sie
dafür im gefängnis gelandet